some of you may have heard this
paradoxical fact about medical tests
it's very commonly used to introduce the
topic of bayes rule in probability
the paradox is that you could take a
test which is highly accurate
in the sense that it gives correct
results to a large majority of the
people taking it and yet
under the right circumstances when
assessing the probability that your
particular test result is correct
you can still land on a very low number
arbitrarily low
in fact in short an accurate test
is not necessarily a very predictive
test
when people think about math and
formulas they don't often think of it as
a design process
i mean maybe in the case of notation
it's easy to see that different choices
are possible
but when it comes to the structure of
the formulas themselves and how we use
them
that's something that people typically
view as fixed
in this video you and i will dig into
this paradox but instead of using it to
talk about the usual version of bayes
rule
i'd like to motivate an alternate
version an alternate design choice
now what's up on the screen now is a
little bit abstract which makes it
difficult to justify that there really
is a substantive difference here
especially when i haven't explained
either one yet to see what i'm talking
about though we should really start by
spending some time a little more
concretely
and just laying out what exactly this
paradox is
[Music]
picture a thousand women and suppose
that one percent of them have breast
cancer
and let's say they all undergo a certain
breast cancer screening
and that nine of those with cancer
correctly get positive results
and there's one false negative and then
suppose that among the remainder without
cancer
89 get false positives and 901
correctly get negative results so if all
you know about a woman
is that she does the screening and she
gets a positive result you don't have
information about symptoms or anything
like that
you know that she's either one of these
nine true positives or one of these 89
false positives
so the probability that she's in the
cancer group given the test result
is 9 divided by 9 plus 89 which is
approximately 1 in 11.
in medical parlance you would call this
the positive predictive value of the
test or ppv
the number of true positives divided by
the total number of positive test
results
you can see where the name comes from to
what extent does a positive test result
actually predict that you have the
disease
now hopefully as i've presented it this
way where we're thinking concretely
about a sample population
all of this makes perfect sense but
where it comes across as
counterintuitive is if you just look at
the accuracy of the test
present it to people as a statistic and
then ask them to make judgments about
their test result
test accuracy is not actually one number
but two
first you ask how often is the test
correct on those with the disease
this is known as the test sensitivity as
in how sensitive is it to detecting the
presence of the disease
in our example test sensitivity is 9 in
10 or 90
and another way to say the same fact
would be to say the false negative rate
is 10
and then a separate not necessarily
related number
is how often it's correct for those
without the disease which is known as
the test
specificity as in our positive results
caused specifically by the disease or
are there confounding triggers giving
false positives
in our example the specificity is about
91
or another way to say the same fact
would be to say the false positive rate
is nine percent so the paradox here
is that in one sense the test is over 90
accurate it gives correct results to
over 90 of the patients who take it
and yet if you learn that someone gets a
positive result without any added
information
there's actually only a 1 in 11 chance
that that particular result is accurate
this is a bit of a problem because of
all of the places for math to be
counter-intuitive
medical tests are one area where it
matters a lot in 2006 and 2007 the
psychologist garrett gigarenzer gave a
series of statistics seminars to
practicing gynecologists
and he opened with the following example
a 50 year old woman
no symptoms participates in a routine
mammography screening
she tests positive is alarmed and wants
to know from you whether she has breast
cancer for certain or what her chances
are
apart from the screening result you know
nothing else about this woman
in that seminar the doctors were then
told that the prevalence of breast
cancer for women of this age is about
one percent
and then to suppose that the test
sensitivity is 90
and that its specificity was 91 you
might notice these are exactly the same
numbers from the example that you and i
just looked at
this is where i got them so having
already thought it through
you and i know the answer it's about 1
in 11. however the doctors in this
session were not primed with the
suggestion to picture a concrete sample
of a thousand individuals the way that
you and i had
all they saw were these numbers they
were then asked
how many women who test positive
actually have breast cancer
what is the best answer and they were
presented with these four choices
in one of the sessions over half the
doctors present
said that the correct answer was nine
and ten which is
way off only a fifth of them gave the
correct answer
which is worse than what it would have
been if everybody had randomly guessed
it might seem a little extreme to be
calling this a paradox
i mean it's just a fact it's not
something intrinsically
self-contradictory
but as these seminars with gigarenser
show people
including doctors definitely find it
counterintuitive that a test with high
accuracy
can give you such a low predictive value
we might call this a vertical paradox
which refers to facts that are
provably true but which nevertheless can
feel false when phrased a certain way
it's sort of the softest form of a
paradox saying more about human
psychology than about logic
the question is how we can combat this
where we're going with this by the way
is that i want you to be able to look at
numbers like this
and quickly estimate in your head that
it means the predictive value of a
positive test
should be around 1 and 11. or if i
changed things and asked what if it was
10
of the population who had breast cancer
you should be able to quickly turn
around
and say that the final answer would be a
little over 50
or if i said imagine a really low
prevalence something like 0.1 percent
of patients having cancer you should
again quickly estimate that the
predictive value of the test is around 1
in 100
that 1 in 100 of those with positive
test results in that case would have
cancer
or let's say we go back to the 1
prevalence but i make the test more
accurate i tell you to imagine the
specificity is 99
there you should be able to relatively
quickly estimate that the answer is
a little less than 50 the hope is that
you're doing all of this with minimal
calculations in your head
now the goals of quick calculations
might feel very different from the goals
of addressing whatever misconception
underlies this paradox
but they actually go hand in hand let me
show you what i mean
on the side of addressing misconceptions
what would you tell to the people in
that seminar who answered nine and ten
what fundamental misconception are they
revealing
what i might tell them is that in much
the same way that you shouldn't think of
tests as telling you deterministically
whether you have a disease
you shouldn't even think of them as
telling you your chances of having a
disease
instead the healthy view of what tests
do
is that they update your chances
in our example before taking the test a
patient's chances of having cancer were
one in a hundred
in bayesian terms we call this the prior
probability
the effect of this test was to update
that prior by almost an
order of magnitude up to around one and
eleven
the accuracy of a test is telling us
about the strength of this updating
it's not telling us a final answer what
does this have to do with quick
approximations
well a key number for those
approximations is something called the
bayes factor
and the very act of defining this number
serves to reinforce
this central lesson about reframing what
it is the tests do
you see one of the things that makes
test statistics so very confusing
is that there are at least four numbers
that you'll hear associated with them
for those with the disease there's the
sensitivity and the false negative rate
and then for those without there's the
specificity in the false positive rate
and none of these numbers actually tell
you the thing you want to know
luckily if you want to interpret a
positive test result
you can pull out just one number to
focus on from all this take the
sensitivity divided by the false
positive rate
in other words how much more likely are
you to see the positive test result
with cancer versus without in our
example
this number is 10. this is the bayes
factor
also sometimes called the likelihood
ratio
a very handy rule of thumb is that to
update a small prior
or at least to approximate the answer
you simply multiply it by the base
factor
so in our example where the prior was 1
and 100 you would estimate that the
final answer should be around one and
ten
which is in fact slightly above the true
correct answer
so based on this rule of thumb if i
asked you what would happen if the prior
from our example was instead
one in a thousand you could quickly
estimate that the effect of the test
should be to update those chances
to around one in a hundred and in fact
take a moment to check yourself by
thinking through a sample population
in this case you might picture 10 000
patients where only 10 of them really
have cancer and then based on that 90
sensitivity we would expect nine of
those cancer cases to give true
positives
and on the other side and 91 specificity
means that
nine percent of those without cancer are
getting false positives
so we'd expect nine percent of the
remaining patients which is around 900
to give false positive results here with
such a low prevalence the false
positives really do dominate the true
positives
so the probability that a randomly
chosen positive case from this
population
actually has cancer is only around one
percent
just like the rule of thumb predicted
now this rule of thumb clearly cannot
work for higher priors
for example they would predict that a
prior of 10
gets updated all the way to 100
certainty but that can't be right
in fact take a moment to think through
what the answer should be again
using a sample population maybe this
time we picture 10 out of 100 having
cancer
again based on the 90 sensitivity of the
test we'd expect 9 of those true cancer
cases to get positive results
but what about the false positives how
many do we expect there
about 9 of the remaining ninety about
eight
so upon seeing a positive test result it
tells you that you're either one of
these nine true positives
or one of the eight false positives so
this means the chances are a little over
fifty percent
roughly 9 out of 17 or 53
at this point having dared to dream that
bayesian updating could look as simple
as multiplication
you might tear down your hopes and
pragmatically acknowledge sometimes life
is just more complicated than that
except it's not this rule of thumb turns
into a precise mathematical fact
as long as we shift away from talking
about probabilities to instead talking
about
odds if you've ever heard someone talk
about the chances of an event being
one to one or two to one things like
that you already know about odds
with probability we're taking the ratio
of the number of positive cases out of
all possible cases
right things like one and five or one
and ten with odds what you do is take
the ratio of all positive cases
to all negative cases you commonly see
odds written with a colon to emphasize
the distinction
but it's still just a fraction just a
number so an event with a 50
probability would be described as having
one-to-one odds
a ten percent probability is the same as
one to nine odds
and eighty percent probability is the
same as four to one odds
you get the point it's the same
information it still describes the
chances of a random event
but is presented a little differently
like a different unit system
probabilities are constrained between 0
and 1 with even chances sitting at 0.5
but odds range from 0 up to infinity
with even chances
sitting at the number one
the beauty here is that a completely
accurate not even approximating things
way to frame bayes rule
is to say express your prior using odds
and then just multiply by the base
factor
think about what the prior odds are
really saying it's the number of people
with cancer
divided by the number without it here
let's just write that down as a normal
fraction for a moment so we can multiply
it
when you filter down just to those with
positive test results
the number of people with cancer gets
scaled down scaled down by the
probability of seeing a positive test
result
given that someone has cancer and then
similarly the number of people
without cancer also gets scaled down
this time
by the probability of seeing a positive
test result but in that case
so the ratio between these two counts
the new odds upon seeing the test
looks just like the prior odds except
multiplied by this term here
which is exactly the base factor
look back at our example where the bayes
factor was 10 and
as a reminder this came from the 90
sensitivity
divided by the 9 false positive rate how
much more likely are you to see a
positive result with cancer
versus without if the prior is one
percent
expressed as odds this looks like 1 to
99.
so by our rule this gets updated to 10
to 99
which if you want you could convert back
to a probability it would be 10 divided
by 10 plus 99
or about 1 in 11. if instead the prior
was 10
which was the example that tripped up
our rule of thumb earlier
expressed as odds this looks like 1 to
9.
by our simple rule this gets updated to
10 to 9
which you can already read off pretty
intuitively it's a little above even
chances
a little above one to one if you prefer
you can convert it back to a probability
you would write it as 10 out of 19
or about 53 and indeed that is what we
already found by thinking things through
with a sample population
let's say we go back to the one percent
prevalence but i make the test more
accurate
now what if i told you to imagine that
the false positive rate was only one
percent instead of nine percent
what that would mean is that our bayes
factor is 90 instead of 10
the test is doing more work for us in
this case with the more accurate test
it gets updated to 90 to 99 which is a
little less than even chances
something a little under 50 to be more
precise
you could make the conversion back to
probability and work out that it's
around 48
but honestly if you're just going for a
gut feel it's fine to stick with the
odds
do you see what i mean about how just
defining this number helps to combat
potential misconceptions
for anybody who's a little hasty in
connecting test accuracy directly
to your probability of having a disease
it's worth emphasizing that you could
administer
the same test with the same accuracy to
multiple different patients
who all get the same exact result but if
they're coming from different contexts
that result can mean wildly different
things however
the one thing that does stay constant in
every case is the
factor by which each patient's prior
odds get updated
and by the way this whole time we've
been using the prevalence of the disease
which is the proportion of people in a
population who have it
as a substitute for the prior the
probability of having it before
you see a test however that's not
necessarily the case
if there are other known factors things
like symptoms or in the case of a
contagious disease
things like known contacts those also
factor into the prior and they could
potentially make a huge difference
as another side note so far we've only
talked about positive test results
but way more often you would be seeing a
negative test result
the logic there is completely the same
but the base factor that you compute is
going to look different
instead you look at the probability of
seeing this negative test result
with the disease versus without the
disease so in our cancer example this
would have been the
10 false negative rate divided by the 91
specificity or about 1 in 9. in other
words
seeing a negative test result in that
example would reduce your prior odds by
about an order of magnitude
when you write it all out as a formula
here's how it looks it says your odds of
having a disease
given a test result equals your odds
before taking the test the prior odds
times the bayes factor now let's
contrast this with the usual way that
bayes rule is written
which is a bit more complicated in case
you haven't seen it before
it's essentially just what we were doing
with sample populations but you wrap it
all up symbolically
remember how every time we were counting
the number of true positives
and then dividing it by the sum of the
true positives and the false positives
we do just that except instead of
talking about absolute amounts
we talk of each term as a proportion so
the proportion of true positives in the
population
comes from the prior probability of
having the disease multiplied by the
probability of seeing a positive test
result in that case
and then we copy that term down again
into the denominator
and then the proportion of false
positives comes from the prior
probability of not having the disease
times the probability of a positive test
in that case
if you want you could also write this
down with words instead of symbols if
terms like sensitivity and false
positive rate are more comfortable
and this is one of those formulas where
once you say it out loud it seems like a
bit much
but it really is no different from what
we were doing with sample populations
if you wanted to make the whole thing
look simpler you often see this entire
denominator written just as the
probability of seeing a positive test
result
overall while that does make for a
really elegant little expression
if you intend to use this for
calculations it's a little disingenuous
because in practice every single time
you do this you need to break down that
denominator
into two separate parts breaking down
the cases
so taking this more honest
representation of it let's compare our
two versions of bayes rule
and again maybe it looks nicer if we use
the word sensitivity and false positive
rate if nothing else it helps emphasize
which parts of the formula are coming
from statistics about the test accuracy
i mean this actually emphasizes one
thing i really like about the framing
with odds and a base factor
which is that it cleanly factors out the
parts that have to do with the prior and
the parts that have to do with the test
accuracy
but over in the usual formula all of
those are very intermingled together
and this has a very practical benefit
it's really nice if you want to swap out
different priors and easily see their
effects
this is what we were doing earlier but
with the other formula to do that
you have to recompute everything each
time you can't leverage
a pre-computed base factor the same way
the odds framing also makes things
really nice if you want to do
multiple different bayesian updates
based on multiple pieces of evidence
for example let's say you took not one
test but two or you wanted to think
about how the presence of symptoms plays
into it
for each piece of new evidence you see
you always ask the question
how much more likely would you be to see
that with the disease versus without the
disease
each answer to that question gives you a
new bayes factor a new thing that you
multiply by your odds
beyond just making calculations easier
there's something i really like about
attaching a number to test accuracy
that doesn't even look like a
probability i mean if you hear that a
test has
for example a 9 false positive rate
that's just such a disastrously
ambiguous phrase
it's so easy to misinterpret it to mean
there's a 9 chance that your positive
test result is false
but imagine if instead the number that
we heard tacked on to test results
was that the bayes factor for a positive
test result is say
10. there's no room to confuse that for
your probability of having a disease
the entire framing of what a bayes
factor is is that it's something that
acts on a prior it forces your hand to
acknowledge the prior as something
that's separate entirely and highly
necessary to drawing any conclusion
all that said the usual formula is
definitely not without its merits
if you view it not simply as something
to plug numbers into but as an
encapsulation of the sample population
idea that we've been using throughout
you could very easily argue that that's
actually much better for your intuition
after all it's what we were routinely
falling back on in order to check
ourselves
that the bayes factor computation even
made sense in the first place
like any design decision there is no
clear-cut objective best here
but it's almost certainly the case that
giving serious consideration to that
question
will lead you to a better understanding
of bayes rule
also since we're on the topic of kind of
paradoxical things
a friend of mine matt cook recently
wrote a book all about paradoxes
i actually contributed a small chapter
to it with thoughts on the question of
whether math is invented or discovered
and the book as a whole is this really
nice connection of thought-provoking
paradoxical things
ranging from philosophy to math and
physics you can of course find all the
details in the description
[Music]
you